foreign
still hasn't finalized man this thing is
tough when I think it's tough It's like
unlike something I've ever been through
before unfortunately you know
he did get physical with me
[Music]
oh what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
literally the greatest mental health and
marriage podcast that has ever existed
in Human Experience
[Music]
so glad that you're with us we're
talking marriage we're talking parenting
we're talking dating relationships
whatever you got going on in your life
um we're here to walk alongside you and
I'm not always going to have the right
answers but I'll do my best and my
promise is I'll tell the truth and I'll
sit with you and we will figure this
thing out if you want to be on this show
give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k and if you will take two
seconds out of your life and hit the
Subscribe button or the like button or
whatever thumbs upy thing the internet
whatever the internet just tell the
internet say you like us that'd be
awesome and that you are ride or die
with us that would be fantastic
um I've been out sick and I am super
happy to be back man
like a toddler I had an ear infection
what is that
I don't think that's what I had I think
I had some something that was terrible
but they told me it was an ear infection
so
there you go all right let's go to
Shirley in Tampa Florida what's up
Shirley
Shirley you there
yes can you hear me I can hear you
what's happening
how are you partying what are you up to
nothing just here on my early lunch
break to do this call early lunch break
it's like a late breakfast at best good
for you yeah it's kind of basically when
does your shift start
I start at 8am that is unacceptable you
need a new job all right so what's up
what's up
so
um so I've been going through a divorce
um
January still isn't finalized will be
finalized towards the beginning of July
but um man this thing is tough when I
say it's tough It's like unlike
something I've ever been through before
and it's definitely taught me a lot
about myself but it's also put a lot
into perspective for just many things
that I'm coming to realize not like like
I said like emotionally mentally and
even financially like relying on this
person for so long that once that was
gone I completely went into like a
survival mode if that makes sense of
course yeah if you did if you had done
anything less than going to survival
mode there'd be something
you wouldn't be operating right
so good for you that's that was exactly
the right thing for you and your body uh
what happened
uh so him and I were about we were
together for six years
um we did do long distance for four
years I actually lived in Nebraska and I
met him in Vegas that's also a very long
story about a girl way to go surely all
good choices come out of famous
marriages
Vegas but uh he shortly moved here back
to Florida and I was doing College in
Nebraska so I had to wait it out because
I had a full ride
um so I ended up moving here covet of
2020 and uh you know just I think first
just coming into the relationship like
from not from a honeymoon space to being
around each other never living with each
other was just like a completely 180 for
both of us you
say that like you're surprised like man
we we
played lovers on the internet for four
years but then when we got around each
other it was weird yes really of course
it's weird
so so it sounded like after y'all got
together it didn't last long
uh no so I mean we held it out together
for about three years um but it kind of
just recently ended so Christmas of this
year of past year um
unfortunately you know he did get
physical with me
so I'm so sorry I can't lie and say that
was the first time you got physical with
me you know so what was it what was it
about this time that you said that's
enough
[Music]
um
it's funny and I don't want to say it's
funny because even then I still didn't
want to walk away
um it wasn't until you know like his
family kind of got involved because it
was around his family
um so
that was kind of like the straw that
broke the camel's back it was like okay
what are what are we doing here so we
had talked about it after it all that
happened and we were like okay because
we actually did not get married till
this past October
um so we were only married for about
three months and um well in in in it
would be a very rare relationship
that there's that kind of physical abuse
when I say that kind I mean repetitive
it happens more than just one time
it's so egregious that the person's
family gets involved
and probably in defense of you
that there isn't all sorts of other
abuse or all sorts of other
really taking your soul from you and
putting it in a box and putting that and
burying in the backyard
you know what I'm saying
like you yeah it's very common to lose
all of you
yeah definitely I mean when that kind of
just when they got involved it was like
a really like a a step back and that's
when we kind of both sat down and said
okay well now we're married like should
we try marriage counseling should we no
he should try not hitting you
try something yeah yeah definitely um
that's the thing so so what's your
question how can I help you
so my question here is I'm I'm just
having a very hard time forgiving him
like walk away walk away walk away walk
away
walk away yeah
what you're hoping to do is you're
hoping to try to make this thing right
and you can't
and yeah
I think I'm trying to keep like you said
you know walking away and taking control
in matters in my own hands and why does
that why why who told you and this is a
long
um pull through narrative in your life I
would be willing to bet money
that you are not good enough or smart
enough or strong enough to do things on
your own for a while who told you that
because it's myself actually it's bull
crap on a stick yeah but you you earned
that story somewhere
yeah where'd that come from
I honestly think it was kind of my my
upbringing uh with my like you know my
relationship with family and siblings
just kind of like
see how life played out in certain areas
and also having a lot of abandonment
issues like my father passing away when
I was nine and you know my mom getting
married again and my sister leaving the
college and it was just kind of like
as soon as this happened and actually he
was the one to walk away from it
um immediately I went into that like
abandon like I'm not good enough again
here I am
what were you a full ride student what
were you studying
I studied criminology and criminal
justice
what do you what are you gonna do with
with that degree
so I actually uh attempted to become a
cop okay
um so I got through the process through
two different counties and again I got
completely through the whole process but
I didn't get chosen from the candidate
pool so then those were those other
underlying issues were like okay here I
am again not good enough so then I just
started just doing like smaller jobs on
the side and then like now I'm just I'm
personal training did they give you
feedback as to why
um
it was just more so like the
pool I would continue to re-enter that
pool there are such severe
um candidate choices in this country
that somebody with your academic
credentials
um
that a university decided looked at you
and said we're gonna let you go for free
that's how bad we want you here
um somebody with that level of academic
um ability not to mention your personal
training ability like you would be a
star candidate across the country
foreign
that's my world that's the guys I hang
out with I know those guys and
um
they are in in many counties across the
country they're desperate for people to
come in and say I want to be a part of
helping this community and so what I
don't want you to do is to circle the
wagons in one of the most desirable
places to live in the United States
where there happens to be a surplus of
candidates that's just that's just very
rare
but bigger than that
at some point you're going to fall right
back into somebody else
who's going to put their ring through
your nose and drag you around their life
unless you decide for the first time
since you were a little bitty girl
that what I want matters what I need
matters
and the life that I have laid out in
front of me these dreams that I have
I get to see them to fulfillment
and of course having a partner in that
Adventure would be great but I'm worth
more than getting hit
I'm worth more than getting stolen from
because I guarantee you he took your
money worth more than being called
stupid ridiculous because I didn't get a
particular job and I know he cuts you
down
like you're you're worth more than all
of that right
yeah definitely do you believe that
see I I see it and I know it but it's so
hard when you know you are in that
mindset that's right
like I do not I do not believe it like
there's moments where I'm like all right
I'm doing this I'm getting through it
you know like I'm capable of it but then
there are those moments where you're
just like
am I though all right here's your here's
the plan moving forward okay
when we get off this call I want you to
go down to Walmart or just a local store
and I want you to get yourself a small
Journal okay
and I want you to write down in that
journal
four or five I am statements that are
going to be your new identity that
you're going to live into
I am surely and I'm worth being loved
I'm Shirley
and things of unspeakable evil have
happened to me in the past
and I'm about going forward I'm Shirley
and I'm a steward of my mind and my body
and I want you to put those things down
and then I want you to come up with four
or five things not thoughts you can
think
are cultures sick with enough thinking
and feeling
I want you to put four or five things
that you can do
right okay
that come hell or high water unless
you're sick that you're gonna do those
things every day you're going to begin
to lean in and practice these new
identities
okay another thing you gotta do for the
first time in your life and it's going
to cost you some money and I want you to
say for the first time Shirley's worth
this is you need to call a counselor
call my friends at better help they'll
hook you up or
um call a local counselor there in Tampa
I think it'd be good for you to see
somebody in person and I want you to
walk in and sit down and say my dad died
when I was nine
my mom brought another man into the
house when I was 11. my sister left when
I was 14.
I just got out of an abusive marriage
I'm sick and tired of everybody leaving
me and I'm sick and tired of my body
approaching every relationship a Zone
about to be left I'm ready to heal
I want you to have that exact sentence I
want you to write it down and read that
to the therapist
because I don't think you need therapy
we're just gonna sit and talk and chit
chat and talk and chit chat and talking
chit chat you have to heal your body
it is so ready for everybody to leave
you that you will you will accept
anybody and anything
even somebody physically harming you
you're worth so so much more Shirley
so much more
and your friends know it
your ex's family knows it
I know it it's one person left that
needs to know it and that's you
and it's just gonna take some healing
because you've been through hell and
back and you and I could probably sit
and talk for a couple hours and you
could tell me some stories that would
that would make my skin crawl
but you're here and you made it
now you get to decide what are we going
to do next
my hope is for the first time
you're gonna put Shirley first and begin
to love Shirley
that's the path to peace my sister
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
couple of things I'm going to send you
Total Money Makeover and a year
subscription to Financial Peace
University I work at Ramsey Solutions
we're going to teach you how to work
here how to take care of your money I'm
also going to send you a copy of my book
on your past change your future about
dealing with life after it deals with
you what do you do next
and also I want you to stay on the line
I'm gonna send you a copy of my friend
Ken Coleman's book paycheck to purpose
we're gonna help you find that police
officer job that is right for you and it
is out there in this country I promise
you I promise you and on the line I'm
gonna send you all that stuff to get you
launched out of this abusive
relationship and into the next thing
be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hallow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right we are back let's roll out to
Columbus and talk to the Zak what's up
Zach
hi Mr Roy how are you dude I don't know
if I could be much better how are you
oh man it's a hectic life that's all I
can really say for it sounds like you
were four beers in this morning already
you doing all right oh man he is so
currently
I already know my question I asked
before I it already changed because so
I'm going through a divorce currently uh
with my wife she has some mental issues
and stuff and I've tried helping her
over the years and then once we got
married and uh death do his part she
took a little bit too literal because
that because she started going on
Rampages telling me I hope you die I
hope you tell yourself I hope you I'm a
truck driver she's like I hope you die
in your trucks bunch of stuff and then
talks is bad about me to my son and
everything but
I'm just trying to figure out what is
the next step to be smart because like I
don't want I want my son to see her's
mom obviously but like she's bringing
dudes over that not like just that she's
sleeping with but my son's there or
she'll be gone for like a whole week or
like a five you know a whole week and
not even bother to see her son but then
if I do anything and just outlandish
like she took my whole house
from me basically
locked me out of the house call the
police the police said you're just gonna
have to leave because if we come back
you're either we're taking both y'all to
jail or we're just taking you to jail
um what's the what's the current status
of the divorce did you just recently
file
yeah okay
um
rarely is it a hundred percent one-sided
what are you bringing to this that's
making things difficult
I don't even know that's a good question
well here's I'm getting at because
I have a uh like uh
I know my answer but I want to make sure
you can hold it so no alcohol no drugs
you don't got any problems like that no
you've never cheated on her or anything
nope okay
um then I want you to sit down with an
attorney and say I will not stop until I
have a hundred percent full custody my
wife's not well and the child my child
is in danger
right okay
and I want you to always keep in the
back of your mind that this is the
mother of your son so we're not going to
be ugly we're not going to throw
grenades We're not gonna lie but we are
going to go to war and we're gonna get
our our boy
because your son's not safe
okay yeah
and this also means that you're probably
gonna have to change careers
yeah I've already thought about that
yeah hey your son is worth
the journey to hell and back right
yes for sure cool then we're gonna find
something else we can do and you're
probably gonna take a big pay cut and
that's gonna be fine and we're gonna
figure it out
right
but um
the safety of of a child the safety of
your child
um is in question here and as a dad I'm
not gonna have that
I'm not going to dishonor his mother and
I'm not going to run her down around him
no matter what she says about me
anytime you enter into a divorce how old
is this kid
it's about to turn 11 months soon oh
geez Louise man
that's a toddler that's gonna be a tall
order man yeah will she pass a drug test
oh yes okay
it's gonna be a tall order okay
um
it might include some psychiatric
expertise it's gonna it's just gonna be
messy
that's what it comes down to
tell me about it yeah
um so here's here's the deal when you
anytime you enter into a divorce with a
little one you're instantly moving from
a short-term game to a very very long
game and it's not a game I don't like
using that language but
um
you are now
shifting influence you want this 22 or
23 or 24 year old young man
to respect his father
and that means over the next decade or
two you're gonna have to endure your
wife talking really bad about you making
accusations about you saying hard things
if that's who she ends up being
and you're gonna play a long game
because your son will one day Eyes Wide
Open see his dad respect that his mom
kept showing up and kept showing up and
kept showing up despite what the courts
did despite what all the all the hurdles
that kept showing up
okay
yeah and that's what you're gonna have
to decide if you go for short-term win
and burn his mom to the ground you're
gonna lose him too
never thought of it like that though
is that cool yeah and I want you to make
no mistake this woman will be part of
your life for the rest of your life
sure guys you're gonna have to make
peace with that
and I'm doing whatever I can to get full
custody of my son because he's not safe
no why why isn't that inspiring you why
is that freaking you out
because it's like the woman's so
manipulated she couldn't manipulate a
squirrel to eat pineapple instead of a
peanut it's just crazy
but if if you are above board and you're
above reproach then there's nothing to
manipulate
it's true when the judge says Hey I want
all of your phone records and all of
your email records all of your DMs and
you turn yours over and she turns hers
over
right right
if you've got something to hide you got
something to hide if you don't yeah it's
super stressful there's no way this
isn't stressful and let's be honest you
knew this for a long time before you
decide to have a kid with it right
yeah yeah
I mean so none of this is surprising but
it does suck I'm sorry like just just
dad to Dad this is hard man
it's hard enough and I gotta I've got
the greatest wife and mother on planet
Earth on my side on my team and it's
hard
I've never had to do what you have to do
and I'm sorry
I guess most of the other shows would be
because my mom and dad went to the same
thing and that's a whole nother Journey
on the Zone my dad did Mom did never
tell my dad that I was actually alive
and it was a whole thing and I'm like
that's the one thing I never wanted to
happen I actually went like a whole
family for once and that she just
started going crazy I was like this is
not gonna go
is do you think this thing's Beyond
repair
oh yeah okay I tried making it work for
the longest I'd let she one minute she
wants to work with it then the next
minute she doesn't that it makes me she
does but then she'll find a find like
how I she has met a whole other guy and
starts leaving for a whole week with him
I'm like okay
your wife
yeah yeah found a guy over Tick Tock and
literally said I'll be back I'm gonna go
hang out with some girls and then I
checked their call log and then it was a
dude from Texas yeah
she's off meds yup yeah she just started
taking him because she met this guy I've
been trying to get her just to we try to
figure everything out she just wouldn't
take him yeah
that's hard man I'm sorry
I'm sorry
um keep your integrity about you keep
your um be the dad that you want your
son to be around
um even when it's hard and it's gonna
get really tough it's gonna get tough
but the more above board you stay
um and I say this fight hard for your
son
don't be passive here because this is
the health and safety of your child
right
um
but be a person of Integrity as you do
so
and I hope that the courts will honor
you and the dad you're trying to be and
the unsafe situation he's in and don't
hold anything back tell the truth always
tell the truth and get yourself a dog
fighting lawyer that will that will um
fight on your behalf
[Music]
this is tough this is tough this is
tough man I'm sorry I'm sorry
um I wish this is one of those calls
that I wish I could like just tell you
this thing and it's all gonna be okay
it's not it's gonna be really tough for
a season and um so if I can help you in
any way as we as you as you travel this
this is a gauntlet ahead of you man uh
holler back and we'll be here every step
of the way my brother
we'll be right back
what is up Dr John deloney here and
we've got to talk about sleep when life
gets hectic it's the first thing we
neglect we stay up later to work we
binge watch more Netflix we think we can
do it all and we're just gonna sleep
when we're dead I've been guilty of
thinking that way but you and me all of
us we need to change we have to we need
sleep sleep is at the core of every
mental physical and relational thing we
do and I've learned good night's sleep
starts with a great mattress and that's
why I love dream Cloud mattresses and
right now dream cloud is running their
biggest offer ever 40 percent off all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings exclusively from my
listeners so it's time to prioritize
getting the rest your body and your mind
need because your mental health matters
all the time go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code John deloney today
that's your dreamcloudsleep.com with Co
John deloney
all right we're back and we're gonna go
to Rachel in Boston I guess it sounds
better when it's Roxanne what's up
Rachel
hi John how's how are you I I yeah we
were partying literally partying how
about you
what are you talking to
you Beyonce's super jealous because to
be on this call but is it about him
it is about him oh yes why isn't he on
at work right now well it's what he gets
for having a job we get to talk about
him all right so what did you do
okay um so my question is how can my
fiance make solid friendships
um and so I wrote in because I know how
important it is to have solid friendship
to spend time with and show up for each
other whenever there's a need my fiancee
and I are getting married at the end of
this month and he's been disappointed by
many of his groomsmen who are the closer
friends that he has but over the years I
haven't seen them reach out or do
anything that wasn't convenient for them
my fiance is so thoughtful and always
willing to help in ways that amaze me he
doesn't receive the same level of care
that he puts out for them it's coming to
the point where he'll say I don't need
anyone anyway and that makes me really
sad and also concerns me
um he is so deserving of great
friendships so my question is how can
you find and develop better friendships
to create a solid group of guy friends
so can I ask you a personal question
you promise you'll answer
yeah that sounded like the most eloquent
way of saying I don't like my husband's
friends
yeah do you hate his friends
um that's a strong word I wouldn't say
that I know because you're an eloquent
kind of person but do you hate his
friends
I still don't think I would say hey
do you struck it's so ridiculous do you
strongly dislike them
uh no even worse even worse you know
what you don't I don't think you hate
them I think you're disappointed by them
I'm disappointed yes like you're their
third grade teacher I'm just
disappointed
oh yeah so are these is like ride or die
buddies have been around for a long time
uh some of them yes some of them it's
been yeah they've all known him longer
than I've known him
um how much of that is plays into this
here's why and and you can tell me I'm
wrong
it is not uncommon for a fiance to come
in and be jealous of the one thing that
a group of friends that an ex-girlfriend
or an ex-boyfriend they're always gonna
have this one thing no matter what we
could have kids we could have a home we
could have whatever
they will always have this one thing on
us time
they'll always have those jokes I wasn't
a part of they'll always have these
get-togethers I wasn't there for they
always have this one time they all got
drunk and they did this or that one time
that
is that part of it
no okay
you promise
yes okay so really in all honesty if you
mind your soul
if these guys were ride or die and he
was hanging out with him once a week or
once every couple of weeks or whatever
that would feel that would fill you up
yeah okay
and so you're watching somebody that you
love get treated like crap is what
basically is boiled down to
yeah okay the unfortunate answer here is
you can do nothing for him
he's got to choose that he's worthy of
having friends that actually are worth
being friends
and that's hard
you don't like that answer
um I wish I could do something but I do
recognize that it's up to him do you
have friends
oh I have the most amazing friends I'm
very blessed okay
what is it about him that he doesn't see
himself as worthy of having friends
and he was kind of
left out of everything so he doesn't
have the most the highest self-esteem in
that area okay
is there some of your friends
partners that he could hang out with
like they all do couple stuff sounds so
gross when I say that
um
no not in this
they're all kind of spread out across
the country
so I would tell you you're gonna need to
make new friends in your area also
and so you're you're how old are you
25 25 okay so here's what's gonna happen
and I'm gonna paint you a very
depressing picture is that okay
okay all right so your entire life since
you were zero has been curated
you go to elementary school you go to
pre-k or kindergarten and then
elementary school and they put you on
the same row like you're on the red
robins row and you're on the uh the
tennis racket row or whatever and and
you're on the baseballs you're in the
basketballs whatever
and then you go to elementary school and
it's like
some of you play kickball and then some
of you hate kickball and then those
become your friends and the the like
sweaty dudes are like yeah bro we're all
into kickball like they become friends
and then you go to music music class and
it's like Tata and some people like oh
my gosh and some people like their soul
lights up
and then it goes to middle school and
then high school and then you get into
theater into sports or whatever your
thing is or doing nothing is your thing
and then you go to college and you have
a major and a sorority or uh whatever
the thing everything is is optimized for
you
you go to the military you go to
Community College and you have group
projects whatever the thing is
and then you get out into the real world
and you get married and you move to your
new town and the whole it's all you
verse the whole world
what do you do for a living
me yes
um I currently well I'm switching jobs
okay what are you gonna be what are you
gonna be doing
uh camp director okay so if you get
somebody to go to your camp
it's gonna because it's gonna be because
they didn't go to somebody else's camp
and that other Camp is going to put
promotional materials and come up with
new rides and new like learning
objectives or whatever to get kids from
your Camp to go to their camp
and you're going to spend your time
trying to get kids to go to your camp
and take care of those kids that are at
your camp
see what I'm saying it's you versus the
world now
and you're gonna have to find your
friends your ride or die your best
friends in the world they're going to
get married and they're going to have
families and it's going to turn into
weekly calls or everyday calls turn into
weekly calls turn into text turn into
long strings of emojis and funny back
and forths
and maybe annual get-togethers and then
biannual get-togethers and if you're not
careful you wake up and you're 33
and you and your husband are sitting on
the same couch and he's on ESPN fantasy
sports and you are researching pallet
walls or whatever it is you're into
see what I'm saying and what I just
painted you I just painted you the
picture of the American life right now
as we're all living it
unless you get hyperintentional you
Rachel get hyperintentional about making
friends in your new area new friends new
relationships new Rider dies
and
if you make that a part of your life
your husband's going to have to not
choose to opt in he's gonna have to
choose to opt out of that
and it's easier to opt it's harder to
opt out of something it is to opt in
see what I'm saying so I'm what I'm
telling you is the greatest gift you can
give him is the practice of making new
friends hey once a week we're going to
have somebody over
we're going to have a messy house and we
don't even care and we're going to meet
a couple of people that we work with
we're going to meet a couple people at a
local church or at the gym or whatever
wherever we meet folks and we're just
going to be weird and we're going to go
first
and I've made some of my life's best
friends doing that and I've had some of
the most awkward worst interactions of
my life doing that too
does that sound nutty
that sounds like really good advice but
it's also depressing like in a yeah not
in a like clinical way but it's a it's
like I want to be friends with my
friends forever
um I did something this past weekend so
I went to Texas for some speaking events
and
um I had four events in three days
and I went a day early I just turned in
a book draft I'm ex I am exhausted out
of my mind and I went to hang out with
some of my 30 year old friends my oldest
friends on the planet
um
two guys that um I trust with everything
in my life
and I haven't lived in this city for
five years now
and
the first thing I got off the airplane
and I traveled so much I lived in this
community for 20 years and I couldn't
quite remember the right exit and I
remember thinking whoa that's weird
and then we all hung out and their kids
were old I didn't even recognize two of
their kids when they walked in the room
I was like oh my gosh they got old
and then I I realized like we are still
best friends I still love those guys I
love their wives I love their kids like
they're my own
and we have very different lives now
and it was a sense of grief and a sense
of mourning and a sense of loss you know
what I mean
yeah because we did everything together
all the time
always
even something as simple as I went in
the garage and my first I was like when
did y'all get these cars and why didn't
you tell me and then it's like oh
because you live 2 000 miles away idiot
right like I'm outside of that little
Loop that's gonna be your life whether
you want it to or not and so if you're
intentional about what comes next it's a
totally different ride than if you just
it happens to you and suddenly you wake
up and it's gone
right does that make sense
yeah and if you're watching your husband
get beat up all the time
there is something profound about
sitting across from a man
and holding his hand and look at him in
the eye and saying
you're an absolute badass and you're
worth more than this
and I'm proud of you and I want you to
find men who respect you like I do
see what I'm saying
yeah I was married for 15 years before I
um had the courage and I was embarrassed
to do it because I was ashamed
to tell my wife hey it would mean the
world to me if you just called out that
you're proud of me
and it was like I was tearful I was
weeping I was like man I can't believe
I'm having to say this out loud not that
she hadn't said it but I'm I can't
believe that this means something to me
and it did
and it when she was like oh my gosh I
wish I'd known because I'm so proud of
you I tell everybody I just didn't know
that was a thing that you needed to hear
I felt weird
um it was a reorientation for me like I
could stand up a little bit taller
and when people blow me off or they're
uglier they're rude or whatever like I
can move on with my day because I got
her by my side does that make sense
yeah there's like a reinforcing thing
and I know that sounds weird that you
don't want to be the person reinforcing
him but man it's a powerful thing to
have a woman who loves you look across
the table and say I believe in you and
you're worth more than this nonsense
is that fair
yeah I'm throwing a lot at you what do
you think back
I feel like I freaked you out a little
bit Rachel
um I just process a little slow
um
uh what's he gonna say if you sit down
and tell him that
that I'm proud of him yep
oh I tell them that all the time yeah
but I mean mean it
and tell him that he's worth good
friends
I have meant it
well good keep telling him yeah I I I
can do it more often
awesome
he's lucky to have you I want you to be
um
worried about the things that you can
control
which unfortunately are not how many
friends he chooses to have
what you can control is how many new
relationships and new friends you make
in your new town at your new job in your
new community in this new life you're
building together with your fiance
that is what you can control
and invite him along for every step of
the way
and don't make him go to weird things
where people wear super short shorts and
boat shoes but like cool things
I don't know that may be cool for you
guys and don't make him play golf but
like invite him to cool stuff
and give him a voice
[Music]
but make friends a part of y'all's new
life together
and I promise he'll pick up that baton
and make friendship and connection an
important part of his life too
thank you for loving him so much man the
world needs more fiance's like you we'll
be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as you wrap up today's show
we're skipping the lyrics we're going
with some good news check this out
um this is an article from CBS News I
didn't even know CBS did news anymore
um it says seeing her there cuddled up
with her crossword you would never guess
80 year old retired school teacher Jenny
shrappen
number one that's a joke name Jenny
shrapen if my name was John Trappin that
would be incredible had a pen pal and a
Penitentiary especially not one accused
of murder 25 years ago a deep deacon at
trappin's church handed her a letter
from a prisoner
um hoping that somebody would write him
back the prisoner was Lamar Johnson a
man serving a life sentence in Missouri
um he was in prison for murder
um
the two struck up a fast friendship and
wrote back and forth over 20 years she
said she could tell right from the start
there was no way he had committed murder
I mean
I mean I mean but 28 years later the
state of Missouri confirmed her
intuition after the Midwest Innocence
Project and let me just stop right there
um y'all know I worked at a law school
for many years the Innocence Project is
one of those incredible groups of people
in the world they are amazing and they
work with law students and attorneys all
over the place the work that the
Innocence Project does is just Second To
None I just applaud them with all my
guts man
um watching the work they do and how
hard they work to try to figure stuff
out it's just amazing the Midwest
Innocence Project if you want to know
more we'll put a link in the show notes
they're just they're just I love them
they got involved in the real killer
confess Johnson was exonerated and
released from prison at 49 years old
he went to shrapan's house for the first
time where she greeted him with a warm
welcome gave him a tour a box of his
favorite cereal and one last letter
he said the greatest gift though is the
confidence his friend instilled in him
especially when somebody's innocent you
want someone to believe in you because
when you have people who believe in you
and they won't give up on you then it
makes it harder for you to give up on
yourself
so whether it's your kids
whether it's your neighbor
whether it's that kid at church that you
see or that kid in the neighborhood on
your on your son or daughter's ball Club
[Music]
find a kid find a person find an adult
that you work with
let them know over a long period of time
I believe in you because when you
believe in somebody it's hard for them
not to believe in themselves
give that away give belief away and the
whole world will get a little bit
brighter
y'all stay in school don't do drugs love
y'all
[Music]